hey everybody it's Ashton Sanders and
I'm shamik Moore and uh we're from the
original Hulu series of Wu-Tang in
American soccer we pick up six months
after season two left off with the group
moving from Staten Island to New Jersey
now they've already started seeing a
huge success but their journey to World
Domination has only just begun so if you
want to see what's next in the Saga
stream Wu-Tang and American soccer
season three and stick around and find
out what else is coming to Hulu this
month
foreign
[Music]
is looking for the next thing my point
is is that we have to do everything the
whole opposition while we got it Wu-Tang
always needs to be moving forward stop
trying to control everything it's only a
matter of time before they start to
present you flaw why are you changing
our brand y'all can't just trust me yo
how about you trust us we got work to do
killer be careful you want us to do it
we gotta win
extortion sex trafficking money
laundering and racketeering
I was in a freaking cult we called it
the Sarah Lawrence bubble it feels like
its own little world they were trying to
attract the kind of students who were
left casts in high school who lived in
the house said hey guys this is my dad
he just looked like a dad everyone
thought Italia's Dad it was weird then
one by one he would get them alone and
suddenly they're like he's the best
thing that ever happened to me I had
never seen anything like that before he
said to me I'm building
I had a lot of theories but none of them
were as horrible as what was actually to
come Larry had this really big thing
about accountability which states that
need to be addressed to get addressed I
was enrolled in this sexual education
Claudia was an escort she was given
the dollars how much worse can I get
it you just looked like a dad my name is
Cara I'm going to travel the world to
discover what makes each of us who we
are I was a teenager when I started
modeling this is the first time I've
spoken about my sex life I'm going on a
journey to discover what else there is
I'm going to meet people like me and
others very unlike me am I brave enough
to change the narrative and shed the
shame
did you get no fight or something yeah
did you get yours
no the left left right
there's some things about my past
have you around that stay away
let's go Darius
talk to him
he's always pretending to be this person
I know he's not
foreign
I work for nightly press this one is my
favorite it is a book about the
possibility of finding great love at any
age don't you just love that
this isn't like a date is it
I'm teasing
so today would be more romantic oh it's
very romantic a black man walked up to
you and hit on you in a bookstore he's
genuine a nice guy I can't next time we
can just bring a relief to Terence sit
her right over there he just suggested a
threesome didn't he it's a wonderful
night hey she is a high school friend
this is your fantasy don't get jealous
Lacey this is your fantasy I'm nervous
as hell
is being yourself
I'm ready she's just a dresser and
you're the turkey enjoy the stuffing
goodbye
I'm actually really happy I came out
with you it's nice to be out of the city
[Music]
I've made a friend of this is Anna nice
to meet you
it's never too late for something I love
what is going on between you guys
there's nothing going on to get one
thing you have to lose something else
you know when you hear a girl saying
like oh I was so calm last night I
shouldn't have slept with that guy we
could be that mistake Evan hey hey Becca
hello
[Music]
people will do Despicable things to get
their hands on a fortune I think my
niece Ally was pushed off that ledge
and only one person came into an
eight-figure sum as a result of her
death you're going to be my eyes and
ears around the greyborn how am I oh yes
you are
I am here in Paris to find love I'm
ready to try something different I'm
serious about finding a French husband
someone isn't here for the right reason
this is not a joke to me I don't want to
get my heart broken
I'm not a player I'm a winner if you
want to fight You're Gonna Lose
this is pretty amazing I'm Never Gonna
Leave Paris so what do you do
I'm a yoga instructor you pageant queen
turned rocket scientist I bet those
pageants really prepared you for NASA
tell me something true I'm a criminal
I'm CIA
as a journalist I've learned it's
important to grab the reader's attention
with a catchy headline here's mine Local
woman ruins own life
what are you gonna put me on the
deadbeat oh my God you're putting me on
obituaries don't you come any closer I
would kill you I'm already dead fun fact
you're the only one that can see me
no no it's a yes for me
[Applause]
[Music]
you're going to Hollywood
who will win big and be the next
American Idol
welcome to the world's toughest coloring
competition all the drama takes place on
a three-story kitchen the top level will
get the first pick of ingredients the
basement you'll have to make do with
what's ever left we're on the top let's
stay on the top cook your way out of
this basement it's a dungeon
the house is on fire all units any units
we comes to protecting the world's
cuddliest creatures
[Music]
you need Animal Control
foreign
[Music]